136 coffins for the unburied a stripper
in inter remains which have only just
been identified now 20 years on they
will be put to rest in the town cemetery
it's a chance for relatives to finally
say goodbye red zone was kid she's
burying his brother and an uncle
I was in Trevor in it sir in July 1995
we fled through the forest together it
was bad took me seven days to get to
safety we were together when the
shooting started we then split up and it
was impossible to recognize who was who
I last saw him in the forest I didn't
know where my brother was after that
around 8,000 other Muslim men and boys
shared that fate they were killed by
bosnian serb militias in july 1995
despite the town's designation as a UN
safe zone Serbian Prime Minister
Alexander vouchers attendance at the
ceremony was meant to be assigned a
reconciliation but back in 1995 rootage
was a hard-line Serbian nationalist
something the crowd is clearly not
forgotten people here are angry that
Serbia only recognizes the mask as a
crime not as an act of genocide unlike
most other high-profile guests at
today's ceremony was not spontaneous
military operation or was it the work of
a few vengeful soldiers genocide in
shamanism was the result of a deliberate
plan designed at the very highest
leadership levels Schreiber needs
remains an open wound for Bosnians but
Europeans also have cause to remember
just 20 years after they did so little
to prevent the worst human rights abuses
since World War two taking place on
their doorstep